jetzt geht es um frauen ab 50 deswegen
kann ich meine lesebrille aufsetzen also
es geht um uns zu sagen da ist der sex
in the city von einer 60 jährigen
autorin candace bushnell ist die
urheberin der literarischen grundlage
von sex and the city die serie war
damals fand ich und wir sprechen von vor
ungefähr 20 jahren
was kann man sagen der revolutionär weil
sie bestimmte fragen thematisiert hat
diese popkulturelle vorher gar nicht
verhandelt wurden zum beispiel überhaupt
sexualität einmal aus einer weiblichen
perspektive also ausgangspunkt ist
eigentlich die trennung von candace
bushnell von ihrem mann und der erste
schritt das erstmal kinder
sie verabredet sich zum beispiel mit
einem älteren mann und dann sagt sie zu
ihm er aber du kannst mir doch nicht
erzählen dass die jungen frauen auf dich
stehen und dann sagt er nähe aber die
wollen halt teure handtaschen und dann
kommen die halt bei mir auf ihre kosten
und ich meine das ist echt entschuldigen
dass es so plakativ und billig und und
bedient solche klischees geschieht sind
geschieht weil sie ganz häufig zu
treffen es ist eigentlich schäfers
bedient wird was erwartbar ist es wäre
ja viel lustiger wenn sie irgendein
erwartung brechen könnte wenn sie
irgendetwas unvorhergesehenes einbauen
würde man muss es einfach wirklich nicht
lesen und das sage ich selten das buch
ist jetzt kein literarisches meisterwerk
aber es ist gar kein literarisches werk
ich finde dieses buch ist auf den punkt
oft genug wenn es darum geht ein blick
auf die gesellschaft zu werfen gerade
auf die interaktion von männern und
frauen da finde ich es am sand und da
finde ich es auch erhält fällt für mich
überhaupt nicht in die in die kategorie
literatur sondern weil sie ein buch es
ist ein text manchmal ist es ein
bisschen wie ein ratgeber es gibt auch
eine ebene wo ich das buch eigentlich am
besten finden wenn sie zum beispiel
beschreibt wie schwierig ist eigentlich
ist an der madison avenue einkaufen zu
gehen und lehrmann geurteilt wird von
den verkäuferinnen in den geschäften und
wie ich
es ist dass man genau die gleichen
sachen kauft wie alle anderen
[Musik]
mit anderen worten ist das madison world
blond eine angenehm austauschbare
haarfarbe die vielen frauen gut steht
und mit sich bringt dass sie alle gleich
aussehen was wiederum zur folge hat dass
diese frauen oft mit anderen madison
world blondinen verwechselt werden sogar
von ihren ehemännern also sie hat einen
wahnsinnig lustigen ton aber ich habe
mich ungeheuer daran gestört dass sie
immer so pauschal über frauen und über
männer schreibt drews die beiden
klappentexte und macht euch selber
gedanken zu ihrer eigenen lebenswelt wie
schaut es aus bei frauen über 50 und
finde ich hat es einen beitrag für
unsere gesellschaft geleistet aber dafür
muss man nicht mehr was ein dass hierfür
für schwere populistische kriterien da
kann ich mich genauso gut mit drei
freundinnen unterhalten die können wir
in einer halben stunde genau das senden
ja wie empfindest du denn dieses
gespräch mit den drei freundinnen das
ist doch angenehm ein schlechtes buch
statt eines guten gespräche mit
freundinnen